Shanaya hello
Hi
listen what an emotional send-off after
a season full of heart
um we have so much to touch on about
this crazy experience so let's dive into
it oh God okay how are you feeling you
know being out of the house and being in
jury
I mean I'm definitely going between like
spiraling and being at peace with
everything
I like in the moment was so distraught
so I think now having time to like
reflect on everything I'm going between
like paranoia and relief so it's a
really weird place to be right now okay
all right okay well listen last night
when it was announced that it was a
double eviction like what was going
through your mind after like an already
emotional vote out earlier in the night
I mean look we had been preparing for a
double for weeks like I don't know we're
just all like negative Nancy's expecting
the worst but every pre-eviction we were
out there showing us like where our
stuff is I'm pre-packing so the day
before we had said if it's not a double
we're gonna be annoyed in retrospect I
don't know why we said that like
we've just been anticipating it for so
long that I think we wanted to rip the
Band-Aid off little did I know that I
would be on the other side of that
yeah okay all right well listen like
when Claudia won HOH what were you
hoping the outcome was going to be
I mean in a perfect world we wanted to
see Ty out of that house so when Claudia
wins HOH I'm obviously thrilled because
I'm like okay here I go final five like
this is it so I mean in that moment I
was really frustrated because I wanted
to win but Claudia was in my head the
second best scenario so it was it was
good for sure okay awesome well listen
when Tai won the veto and told Claudia
that he was going to use it you were in
the bathroom with Claudia and Renee why
did you say to the girls that you know
Renee deserved to be in the house more
than you
I was waiting for this question
I have been reflecting on that myself
I feel like it's just in my nature to
take the bullet for my friends and
something that I really struggled with
in the house was feeling like
not necessarily unworthy but I was
really struggling with self-doubt and I
was having a hard time understanding
that my narrative meant something too
you know when I looked at Renee's story
it was so clear for me you know she'd
been on the Block four times she'd been
fighting for her life she'd done this
she done that and I have a hard time
looking at my story which is you know I
was dead last too I was in there
fighting too but it was hard for me to
recognize that it meant it meant the
same as Renee so I think in that moment
I was so like overcome with an emotion
that I was like I felt the guilt taking
that away from Renee because of how much
I valued her journey so was it the
smartest thing to say no probably not
but I weren't vomited okay all right
well I mean do you have any regrets like
now you know saying that now that you're
injury I mean I don't and call me naive
but I don't think think it was me saying
that that actually sent me packing I
believe that it was Thai and he told
Claudia that if he if she puts me up
then he will continue moving forward
with Renee and Claudia and I believe
that's ultimately what sent me home Ty
saw me using the veto as ruining his HOH
week which it kind of did and because of
that he didn't want to move forward in
this house with me so I don't
necessarily think it was that that got
me out what I do regret is not pushing
Claudia to put tie up on the Block
straight away I in the moment was like
oh yeah that's so smart like put up
Daniel put up Anika if Ty wins he won't
use it the I don't know why we didn't
consider in what world he would actually
use it on one of them and screw us over
so that's my regret okay all right well
listen you have been close with Claudia
and Renee All Season the girly pops
Alliance I gotta know what is this
Alliance meant to you not only in the
game but in real life
I mean
there has not been many successful girl
alliances in big brother and I have such
a close group of girlfriends in my
day-to-day life I'm so happy that it
worked out the way it did you know not
without our trials and tribulations
there was a little bit of mistrust going
on between the three of us but
ultimately we were three people that
were really overlooked in that house
right from the get-go we also started
the game as numbers for a guy Alliance
and once we found that out we just had
no time or patience for that and we were
kind of renowned for going against the
house being on the outside figuratively
and literally at the library you know
like we really were there for each other
and truthfully although it ended the way
it did I don't know what I would have
done without them in that house
okay so yeah that leads me to my next
question like do you feel that going
home has impacted this relationship at
all
if you had asked me this like five
minutes after the eviction I would have
said no but having some time to think
about it I don't know if it's like this
paranoia in me that's like maybe this
was planned I definitely have to have
some conversations with them when I see
them hopefully not too soon but
regardless I said to Claudia in the
moment like it's a game we're always
gonna be friends our relationship is so
much more than that I am feeling a
little hurt in this moment but I know
I'll get over it it's just um it's like
Bittersweet but I know it's something
that will be able to move past at least
I hope so all right okay well we gotta
touch on this because earlier in the
week Claudia and Renee were at one point
thinking about keeping Koozie after like
a very convincing pitch so you weren't
on board with this and like why weren't
you buying what she was selling
I mean
I was just so shocked that they were
believing what she was saying after one
conversation with her because I was like
guys especially Claudia Renee not so
much but Claudia and I had been on the
same page that Koozie needed to go oh on
Claudia's HOH and Claudia wanted her out
that week we just felt that we didn't
have the support so I was shocked
because I was like girl you have one
conversation and suddenly you're out
here like considering it it's not
necessarily that I didn't think Koozie
had points but I didn't believe what she
was saying in the sense that Daniel C
and Eniko were targeting us because the
truth is is that of course they were
targeting us it was this three verse
three thing we had going on the minute
that Ty was out of that house the plan
was that we were all going to go after
each other anyway so it's not like it
was anything new and Koozie was such a
force in that house in comps and outside
like in socially so to get her out would
have been a huge benefit for us so I was
just shocked that they were even you
know considering it after one
conversation so I uh yeah that was very
confusing for me right okay well do you
think like you wouldn't be in jury if
maybe you had kept Koozie over Anika
truthfully it's so funny and yeah I I
don't think it would have changed much
to be honest I mean perhaps Koozie would
have won the HOH and not Claudia that
could have maybe happened but the
reality is she likely would have thrown
me up on the Block maybe next to Daniel
or next to Anika because I was the one
vote who wasn't gonna I told her from
the get-go I likely wasn't going to
change my mind about where my vote was
going it would have been very easy for
her to turn around and vote me out so
maybe things would be different but
realistically I still think I would have
been in big danger right all right well
listen I gotta know over the entirety of
the Season what is the game move that
you are most proud of Shania oh okay
well
well exert is
using that veto I gotta say that was one
of the like scariest moments of my life
I am such a people pleaser and to stand
in front of a group of people I knew
that nobody wanted me to use that Beetle
everyone was staring me down and to
stand there and use it on my friend I
was so scared I was wearing the flame
shirt but your girl was trembling and
I'm so proud that I did that I I was
proud of myself and even if it is what
got me out of that house if tide had
some Vendetta against me for that I'm
still I'm so proud of that move
awesome okay well listen like I gotta
know because I feel like you learn a lot
of life lessons in the game of Big
Brother what is something that you're
going to take back to your everyday life
that you learned in this game
oh my gosh so much I think the biggest
thing for me is to
believe in myself and to not doubt
myself I was so hard on myself in that
house and even just having a couple
hours outside of it I was like geez like
I need to just chill out and embrace
myself fully
um you know and the biggest thing for me
too was embrace the losses in the house
I'm sure you know things don't go your
way most the time as opposed to going
your way and you just have to like deal
with the cards that you're dull and make
the best of it and take a bad situation
and do what you can and I feel like that
was literally my journey in that house
up until we started winning things right
okay well listen you might be out of the
house but you are not out of this game
Shanaya you are you know you gotta make
a decision so I want to know what are
the qualities of a player or what's
going to make a player worthy of your
vote in the end
so I think somebody that is well-rounded
is really important you know somebody
who can show that they were playing at
all points throughout the game in
addition to that I want somebody who is
proud of their achievements but is
humble about them you know I don't want
somebody coming in there being like
arrogant or what have you I understand
that people have to come and they have
to toot their own horn and that's fine
but what I think is important and what
you know my plans wherever the final
speech is to acknowledge that ultimately
you've made it to that final space not
just do to yourself but due to many
other people in that house so I think
somebody that can recognize that it's
not just all about them there's been a
journey and there's been many many many
pieces that got them to that spot
all right okay well I gotta know do you
respect more of a social game or a
strategic game
hmm
I would say I respect
ah
I would say the social for sure I think
Big Brother is like 80 social 20 the
rest because you really have to
establish those social relationships
obviously you need a strategy but
somebody coming in there with just peer
strategy and you know gunning for
everything look at who was out at the
first couple weeks it clearly didn't
work for them so I truly think social is
so important in this game
okay all right well you know I gotta ask
you you know this question's coming who
do you think is winning the crown of BB
can 11. look I like begrudgingly say
this I think it's gonna be Thai I think
it truly is I would love I would love
obviously I'm biased we'd love to see my
girls I would love to see Daniel c as
one of the winners but I think it's
gonna be Ty he has bulldozed his way to
this spot truthfully he is so hard to be
in comps and the fact that he's been
able to stand on his own basically since
week four and get this far is
unbelievable and if he makes it to the
end I hate to say it but it would be
very very hard for me not to vote for
him okay all right well thank you so
much shanea what a powerful and
emotional Journey you know
um your time in the house has ended but
you know what you're still part of the
all-powerful jury so so you still have
so much of this experience to enjoy and
we can't wait to watch and see how it
all turns out
um congratulations and welcome to this
crazy Big Brother family
that's so crazy to hear
thank you shanea